cancer it's a word that if I say it to
somebody you have cancer you know they
this is like hitting you on the head
with a club it's a life-changing event
no matter how you look at it my goal is
not to be aggressive as possible kill
everything my job is to make cancer a
liveable manageable condition so that
you live with cancer rather than dying
with cancer and this really is or are
the lucky years with regard to cancer I
want to talk about two kind of
fundamental shifts that are happening
now the first is what we call
immunotherapy when cancer cells happen
they have a don't eat me signal on their
surface when we now have the ability and
there are drugs that are approved that
block that don't eat me signal and allow
the immune system to come in and
basically eat the cancer we've seen this
work with a remarkable 90 plus year old
individual named Jimmy Carter our former
president and we've seen it work with
many other patients so cancer is like
skin cancer melanoma like kidney cancer
some kinds of lung cancer and others
have had some pretty dramatic results
with this immunotherapy and it's only
getting better we're learning at a
harness the power of our own immune
system to attack cancer literally more
on a daily basis number two is what we
call precision or personalized medicine
and they mean the same thing there's a
lot of confusion out there someone
called a precision medicine and
personalized they're the same thing what
it means is I can now for example if you
have cancer I can take a piece of your
cancer and sequence the DNA and look at
what genes are turned on and what genes
are turned off and hopefully develop a
way to turn off the driving genes and it
works it works in many patients not all
in many of the patients we don't yet
know the drivers we don't drugs aren't
turned off every gene but I can sequence
the DNA of the cancer and develop a
personalized therapy of that patients
there may be a drug that was FDA
approved for breast cancer that gene is
driving lung cancer and I can use it in
that patient in the 1800's in Europe
they started to classify cancer by
you're a breast cancer you have prostate
cancer lung cancer the next generation
of students of doctors are going to
classify cancer by what are the on
switches and the off switches and it
doesn't matter what body part it
originating at the same time there's
another way of thinking about cancer
because historically we tape we've got a
target that cancer cell and kill it well
to me cancer is a verb and not a noun
York answering something the body does
and not that the body gets and so that
philosophy means a very different way of
approaching disease and it means
changing the system in addition to
trying to target the cancer so for
example there was a trial done about a
decade ago where they took men women
with premenopausal breast cancer and
normally we treat them and then we wait
for the cancer to recur or we treat
again in this group of women after
treatment we divided it into two half
got a drug that builds bone that was
meant for osteoporosis and half got
placebo and the cancer recurrence was
reduced by about 40%
why because breast cancer metastasizes
to bone so if I change the soil the seed
doesn't grow so one of the most
remarkable advances in a cancer was from
a drug that didn't even touch the cancer
just this week we've seen announced a
trial where patients with advanced
prostate cancer who are on aspirin do
better because aspirin blocks
inflammation there's data out there that
across the board with every cancer
people are on a statin that is the
lipitor Crestor of the world that those
patients do better than patients who are
not why again because those drugs block
inflammation and inflammation allows
cancers to change more over time so if
we can block that change we can get a
better outcome no matter what cancer no
matter what treatment so we're learning
a lot new ways to target the cancer and
treat it immunotherapy molecular
targeted therapy and at the same time
looking to change that system so the
cancer doesn't want to grow because
remember if you drop a match after rains
nothing happens you drop a match in Los
Angeles it goes up in flames I want you
as an individual to be much more like
after arraigns than to be like that
sunny Southern California
you